it's the gadget that waiters are wearing
in an effort to keep restaurant
customers safe from covid19 rich demiro
explains in today's text mark
[Music]
[Applause]
across the united states restaurants
continue to open their doors
but the challenge of keeping customers
and staff safe from covet 19
remains now one restaurant is asking its
employees to wear a gadget
that might help after six months of
staying closed
philip camino is ready to reopen his
restaurant
[Music]
of course concerns surrounding covet 19
are top of mind
which is why in addition to socially
distant seating and hand sanitizer
he's trying something new we're
empowering our employees
to actually take a little bit more
responsibility for their own health
fellow restaurant employees are being
encouraged to wear
a fitness tracker called woop so we look
at all of the things that we're doing
from
a cdc and health department standpoint
is very important but then we sort of
layer on the woo
and it allows us to get a little bit of
a pre-warning system sort of like a
fitbit
minus the screen the lightweight bands
use sensors to measure body stats like
heart rate
sleep and more they're popular with
professional athletes
whoop our core is a data and analytics
company
and we're our mission is really to
unlock human performance
early on woop did some research to see
if their algorithms could detect signs
of covet 19
before humans could we're able to see
really a
some very clear marker in the covet sick
data
and that was an elevated respiratory
rate and 20 of the cases we're able to
see
this elevation three days before symptom
onset
it certainly is this extra layer of
reassurance since the program just got
started only time will tell if it gives
employees an
edge with early detection but it's one
more tool to stop the spread
in hopes of getting life and business
back to normal
investing in your employees health and
wellness is something we should really
all be doubling down on right now
they're the front lines
they're probably most at risk in terms
of
interacting with customers
now the restaurants using woop do not
see their employees data it's up to
staff to get a test if the band notices
something out of the ordinary
a whoop subscription which includes the
band is about thirty dollars a month
if you want to learn more you can go to
my website it is rich on tech dot tv i'm
rich demero and you
are tech smart